vip auto center the sponsors of this
next segment is a female owned auto shop
in town that wants to ensure all members
of the community feel comfortable secure
and like a vip when getting their
vehicle service take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to vip i'm bob myers and we
welcome you to all three locations here
at vip we do everything from a simple
smog
to a complete engine rebuild
transmission rebuild replacement
all the techs at the locations can work
on your simplest car to your electric
car to your diesel truck or car
all of our mechanics are certified
at every location right now we have
service specials as follows 14.99 for
simple wall change 14.99 smog and we
also offer free towing for any of our
customers at any location we also do a
complete engine diagnostic of your
vehicle and we do a complete safety
inspection of your vehicle so you know
when you leave that you have no worries
we proud ourselves with we have a lot of
family
in our company
and we're an equal opportunity employer
so we have as many females working as
mel so welcome to vip thank you our
owner is a female and
we treat women when they come here with
a security knowing that they're not
getting taken advantage of like i said i
have female managers in most of the
stores
and we take pride in what we do for our
customers we don't take advantage
and we want them to have the best
experience that they can have it's what
makes us different is we're family based
family owned and we care about our
customers coming in we from the
beginning to the end from the smile on
the face when they walk in the door to
the handshake in the open the door form
when they're leaving
we value all of our customers no matter
what kind of car you have how much money
you have we treat everybody the same
i want las vegas to know that we are the
number one
automotive repair facility in town we
might not be the biggest but our heart's
in the right place and we have the best
staff that anybody could have
our locations we have one on decatur
close to north las vegas decatur and
craig we have this one that we're at
right now on charleston we have another
one on sahara and two more openings soon
you can reach us at vip auto center
lv.com
[Music]
thank you vip auto center for sponsoring
this segment they have three locations
in the valley for more information just
head to vipautocenterlv.com
and they have a special offer for you
the week of christmas and the week of
new year's take an additional 20 percent
off any major repair